impossible désormais de ne pas connaître
Marco Moulis l'homme derrière l'arnaque
à la taxe carbone une fraude considérée
comme étant le casse du siècle fume bien
à moi qu'on est j'ai gagné si je te dise
c'est même pas moi-même est-ce que tu
vas me croire après le succès de ce
documentaire sur Netflix marque vient de
publier son livre la Kabbale où il
raconte son incroyable périple pour
échapper à justice et il explique
comment il a traversé les frontières
sans être inquiéter je me suis dit bon
la prison elle va m'attendre je me suis
mis en cavale j'ai fait le tour du monde
madame le Roi de l'Arnaque Marco molly
est avec nous ce soir
[Applaudissements]
la course folle du Roi de l'Arnaque ça
va mon Marco d'amour ça va mon frérot
mon frère white tu peux le dire je
t'aime aussi tu le sais ouais
dans les interviews et tout ça bon il y
en a un petit peu qui t'aime et beaucoup
qui t'aime et un petit peu qui t'aime
pas mais pas c'est vrai mais les gens
sont méchants aussi en même pas des fois
mais je sais pas pourquoi à mon avis à
mon avis chez des gens jaloux ils sont
là ils ont envie de regarder quelque
chose toujours une question sur moi j'ai
pas compris alors c'est un avantage
parler de moi en bien ou en moi mais
parler de moi quand même mais tel
avantage qu'on parle de toi Cyril un
amour merci mon frérot d'être là en tout
cas tu es magnifique franchement c'est
quoi
ça c'est quoi ça c'est l'élégance j'aime
bien la coupe un peu plus longue comme
ça ouais c'est pas mal je préfère pas
rager non j'aime bien comme ça d'accord
qu'est-ce que tu dois faire si je peux
me permettre
et là tu es très bien mais ce que j'aime
ce que j'aime c'est quand tu fais un
petit dégradé progressif physique et là
tu laisses un peu plus long d'accord la
prochaine fois je te la mets là c'est
pratiquement comme là c'est très bien
non un peu plus long comme ça j'aime
bien mais tu vois il y a un problème
c'est que là j'ai vu qu'il manquait un
peu de cheveux alors là ça laisse-moi
faire on a on a un stabilo un truc
[Applaudissements]
je te le fais direct
elle est pas mal celle-là franchement
dis-moi frère euh celle-là tu venais de
perdre beaucoup d'oseille quand tu l'as
fait ça là
c'est vénère elle est très bien celle-là
ça me fait penser à une photo de vous
aussi pour un magazine vous aviez
l'avion en feu derrière dans le même
c'était pas l'avion qui était en fait
c'était Daniel euh
non je te dis le Roi de l'Arnaque Marco
Mouli est mon ami aussi Julie Madar que
j'embrasse ma Julie qui est en coulisse
la cavale la course folle du Roi de
l'Arnaque alors tu vas nous raconter
tout ça parce que c'est vrai que ton
histoire passionne les gens tu racontes
ton enfance ta jeunesse dans le quartier
de Belleville ou une jeunesse tu n'as
pas d'argent ou tu te débrouilles on
comprend que des petits tu n'avais qu'un
seul but toi c'était avoir de l'argent
c'est d'être riche je croyais que d'être
riche était un métier déjà ouais je
savais pas que il fallait travailler
pour être riche non plus
je savais pas qu'il fallait travailler
pour être riche et puis tu sais à
Belleville tout le monde était dans la
des merdes tout le monde était essayé tu
avais des gens qui excusez-moi du terme
qui volait un petit peu
pour subvenir aux besoins de ses parents
pour subvenir aux besoins de sa famille
et tu sais quand tu es enfant immigré
quand tu arrives de Tunis et tu arrives
avec une valise marron toute cassée puis
il y a rien à l'intérieur et tu dors
dans un couloir et tu crois que c'est
chez toi tu avais pas d'appartement et
tout ça et puis quand tu arrives à te
réveiller je me suis réveillé très jeune
dans ma vie et ben voilà on a fait une
école de la démerde de la débrouille à
Belleville et j'étais un quartier
d'abord c'était l'époque et qui était
magnifique c'était magnifique parce que
c'était la démerde on mangeait n'importe
quoi on était content on s'assait dans
des chaises cassées on était content moi
tu as fait ta belle ville ou à Koh-Lanta
parce que tu as pas connu je pense que
tu es plus jeune que moi c'est ça ouais
mais bon mes parents quand ils sont
arrivés aussi je te dis je connais la
valise cassée ils m'ont raconté tu sais
et voilà je vous rappelle quand tu
souffrais au poker tu te rappelles quand
tu perdais tout le temps et tu te levais
[Rires]
je te rappelle pas quand tu t'es levé et
tu étais perdant tu voulais trop faire
de l'oseille partout
c'est vrai que je suis très mauvais
perdant il le sait euh
non non
quand même et on peut chercher de
l'oseille pour trop faire c'est ça qui
est beau ça veut dire que tu ne veux pas
perdre ton oseille tu voulais aller
récupérer alors il y avait pas d'oseille
devant je le dis quand vous perdez
n'essayez jamais de vous refaire vous
allez vous faire une jolie mais c'est
vrai c'est vrai alors tu savais que tu
ferais tu savais ce que tu ferais plus
petit ou pas du tout tu avais une idée
ou pas tout c'était quoi ton rêve au
départ tu rêvais de faire quoi
de faire le tour du monde à rester ça
donc voilà de faire le tour du monde
d'aimer une belle femme de ouais bah
ouais je veux pas aimer un homme
voilà regarde non si tu es pas mon je
respecte un jour je règle mon meilleur
ami je sais pas si tu connais c'est ce
qu'ils ont je l'adore si tu connais si
vous attend il est très heureux Steve
mais il est magnifique heureux il est
magnifique et je l'embrasse mon Steve
alors après tes affaires avec l'arnaque
à la taxe carbone on comprend que tu
voulais pas tout du Sud tout du tout
passé des années en prison pas du tout
c'était pas ton truc la prison c'est dur
fini la rigolade c'est moche la prison
il y a rien de plus moche c'est encore
plus moche que l'hôpital quoi la prison
c'est il faut être fou d'abord d'y aller
enfin d'y aller c'est de toute façon
tu sais qu'il y en a qui veulent y aller
pour commencer mais tu sais quand tu
arrives en prison le problème qui se
passe c'est que moi je suis un financier
je suis pas violent je suis pas tout ça
mais quand tu arrives dans ce monde là
quand ils disent les récidivistes les
pauvres
on était obligé de récidiver tu deviens
un lion quand tu arrives là-bas tu te
rends compte que tu es mélangé avec
n'importe qui n'importe quoi que ça soit
un pédophile que ça soit un violent que
ça soit un tueur toi tu arrives tu es
financier tu te dis [ __ ] qu'est-ce que
je veux faire alors tu es obligé de
faire montrer tes dents tu es obligé
d'être fort tu vis dans un autre bled
dans un autre monde dans ta tête elle
doit être toute la journée il y a que du
sport à faire les mecs tu les vois ils
sont comme ça des bras comme ça on
dirait des murs comment tu veux te taper
ah une fois il y a un mec qui est venu
il m'a demandé une bouteille d'huile moi
je voulais lui en donner 10 mais si je
lui en donne un petit peu si je leur
donne 10 c'est comme si qu'on me
rackettait bon j'arrive je fais je ferai
comme eux mais j'en ai pas beaucoup mais
j'en avais 200 moi on est pas beaucoup
je t'emmène un petit peu si tu veux il
me ramène un verre comme ça je lui mets
la moitié il me dit si tu rempouilles
pas la bouteille je te prends tout ce
que tu as dans la cellule
heureusement que la sonnette pour fermer
la porte
[Applaudissements]
il y a rien à manger
[Rires]
je suis en train de faire une moussaka
en prison que j'avais une cellule de 40
mètres carrés
je me démerdais ça va ça faut parler il
y a eu des c'est quoi ton moment le plus
difficile en prison dis-moi
c'est
mon moment de plus difficile c'était
pendant le corona on était alors
je vais expliquer la prison il y a des
blocs donc tu es enfermé dans un bloc où
il y a à peu près une vingtaine de
cellules dans la vingtaine de cellules
quand il y a eu corona nous ne savait
pas mais bon c'était vraiment horrible
pourquoi on était livré à nous-mêmes ça
veut dire tout le monde était avec ce
téléphone tout le monde frappait tout le
monde est souriant on a des pas le droit
de rentrer dans le bloc ça veut dire que
tout le monde faisait ce qu'il voulait
ça veut dire qu'on avait pas de cantine
on avait rien à manger on ne touchait
pas parce qu'il savait pas c'était quoi
la maladie
quand vous mangiez mais la gamelle nous
jeter comme si qu'on était des animaux
comme si qu'on était et tout le monde se
tapait dessus tout le monde se tapait
sur la gamelle bon moi j'avais des
petites cachettes
bon voilà donc c'est de le plus dur
c'était ça c'était le moment le plus
difficile parce que même quand les
pauvres quand tu te fais il y a eu
beaucoup de bagarres quand tu te faisais
frapper les surveillants n'avait pas le
droit d'y aller donc on avait nos
téléphones même devant surveillant il
disait rien voilà c'était un moment très
très difficile ta tête elle devait être
enfin j'étais dans le monopole de dire
[ __ ] qu'est-ce qui va se passer
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui va se passer
comme mal parce que faut pas oublier on
le dit pas et ça je le dis haut et fort
en prison il y a beaucoup de mort
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de morts ne
croyez pas vous savez j'étais à fleuri
il y avait peut-être aller 3 morts par
mois mais des gens qui frappaient des
gens dans les promenades à 20 et tu sais
ils s'entourent tous c'est
vraiment violent c'est vraiment violent
mais les pauvres les prisonniers les
détenus qui soient n'importe qui qui
n'importe quoi il se ils sont livrés à
eux-mêmes donc ils se défendent tu vois
quand il y a des gens parlent qui disent
tu vois pas les prisonniers ils sont là
pour se dire il faut les jeter aux
chiens non les pauvres il faut les aider
le contraire on parle à tout à l'heure
parce qu'il y a Daniel Riolo
Daniel Riolo viendra dans un instant
merci à lui de venir ce qui sera là
Daniel dans quelques minutes
puisqu'il a qualifier les prisonniers
vous avez vu un de tous citoyens ça a
donné un gros débaillère et Daniel a
accepté notre invitation donc merci à
lui il sera avec nous dans un instant je
peux poser une question on t'a pas cassé
la gueule toi avec tes 283 millions
planqués alors j'avais j'avais un
avantage ouais c'est que le plus fort je
disais t'inquiète pas dehors on va se
refaire et les mecs ok on a compris donc
il y a une fois une vraie bagarre j'ai
réussi à détourner la bagarre alors je
lui ai dit écoute moi ça sert à rien que
je te frappe bon j'aurais pris une année
c'était le champion d'Afrique de boxe
Julie chasse à rien devant tout le monde
ça sert à rien que je te frappe mais si
tu veux on met des gants et il y a une
vidéo sur les gants avec lui le mec
c'est une masse comme ça et tout ça je
vais essayer de deviner comment j'allais
faire pour l'éclater parce que il y
avait les autres prisonniers puis bon
j'ai triché un petit peu j'ai mis un
mauvais coup dans le genou le mec il a
boitait j'ai dit j'ai gagné
[Rires]
il faut essayer il faut essayer de
essayer de se refaire c'est un monde
c'est un monde à part je te le promets
tu vois monsieur Siliva
tu sais je vais t'expliquer une fois
j'étais enfermé dans un ouais parce
qu'il avait la même tête
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est la vérité excuse-moi de te
dire ça vraiment la même tête
et tu sais moi j'étais en cellules
séparé de tout le monde quand j'allais
au parloir quand j'allais aux avocats et
je vais dans une cellule une fois il y a
un mec alors je t'explique c'est où un
pédophile quand il y a un mec c'est ou
un pédophile ou un violeur qui peut
mettre dans ses cellules donc moi je
parle pas tranquille puis je le vois
gentil tu vois je le vois bien puis ça
va toi mais tu sais technique prison tu
vois il faut parler comme ça va toi
alors pourquoi tu es là je peux pas te
dire oh j'ai dit bon qu'est-ce que tu as
fait et à la fin le pauvre il est rentré
pour défaut de permis six fois attraper
mais c'est un mec qui travaillait le
pauvre il a voilà défaut de permis il a
pris deux ans il a accroché une voiture
et où ça m'a fait vraiment de la peine
où ça m'a fait vraiment de la peine je
dis mais pourquoi tu es pas bien tu es
là tu es là ne souffre pas tu vas sortir
un jour ou l'autre quoi qu'il arrive il
me dit on vient de me violer et là
franchement j'ai eu peur pour mon cul
voilà non mais c'est sérieux
les hommes là-bas n'oublie pas qu'ils
sont privés tout ça d'amour de tout ça
et tu sais le plus important de savoir
c'est qu'il y a des gens beaucoup de
prisonniers bon bah pas beaucoup mais tu
en as
quand ils sont à deux en cellule ils
font ce qu'ils ont à faire ça veut dire
qu'il y a pas de il faut en réalité un
être humain il a droit de tout avoir
même si l'enfermé déjà d'être privé de
liberté
ça c'est horrible tu sais pas qu'est-ce
qui arrive à ta famille tu sais pas s'il
y a des problèmes et pixels quand on
ferme 7 ans j'étais enfermé 7 ans
quand tu sors la vie est complètement
différente les gens qui ont vécu dehors
ils ont l'habitude de voir cette vie là
toi tu sors tu crois il y a un problème
qui est plus dans la même vie tu es dans
la vie de la prison donc on vient de
voir tu te comprend en prison tu crois
encore te battre donc c'est pour ça
qu'on dit la réhabilitation
je l'ai bien dit Monsieur la
réhabilitation tu ne peux pas l'avoir
c'est impossible les gens qui sont
obligés de récidiver tu rentres un
toutou tu ressors un lion d'accord et tu
sais même pas où tu vas donc c'est pour
ça qu'il faut pardonner les prisonniers
il faut les aider et ça c'est rien il
faut vraiment les aider parce qu'ils
sont dans une situation anormale alors
on en reparlera tout à l'heure mais tu
pardon à tous les les présidents parce
que nous on a on a enlevé hier les les
pédocrinels voilà et les terroristes
mais cela alors alors les les violeurs
les pédophiles les terroristes je veux
te dire la vérité mais il mérite de
souffrir tu ne peux pas savoir il
méritent même pas de mourir parce que
mourir c'est facile souffrir marchés
différents comment ils font souffrir des
familles comment ils font souffrir la
personne tu prends un pédophile ou un
violeur mais chez moi je suis que j'ai
envie de lui faire j'ai envie de
l'ouvrir la jambe mettre des piments et
de la Rissa le recoudre pour qu'il
s'ouvre toute sa vie tellement que j'ai
la haine contre lui parce que les gens
souffrent une fille c'est trop facile
c'est trop facile de lui faire du Marco
c'est quoi ton moment où tu as eu le
plus peur en prison après on va parler
de ta cavale le piment le moment où j'ai
eu plus peur alors tu connais l'avocat
Kaminsky je l'embrasse d'ailleurs un
jour moi mais c'est un bon mec mais
c'est un inventeur l'avantage c'est un
vendeur d'espoir et je l'ai pris parce
que ça a un menteur tu sais moi j'avais
beaucoup d'avocats énormément d'avant
cas et j'ai dit qui peut me remonter le
moral je dis c'est quand même ski et
Kaminsky il arrive à peine il me dit ça
va Marcos ça va et toi je dis ouais
dis-moi j'en ai d'arriver moi j'ai pris
8 ans je dis c'est quoi quand je peux
sortir tu vois une 17 ans que tu sors
c'est incroyable mais moi j'ai voulu
croire assez beau de l'espérance de
croire j'ai été voir ma femme j'ai 7 ans
que je sors Noël elle m'a regardé elle
dit tu te fous de ma gueule je lui
appelle quand même
ce qui m'a appelé il me dit c'est sûr
j'ai combien ça coûte il me dit 50 000
hein il me dit tu veux sortir au mois de
septembre et c'est comme ça que les
vendeurs d'espoir arrivent et puis tu es
là tu es là tu payes tu payes tu payes
en réalité tu fais ta peine en réalité
tu vas au bout de ta peine à Part Dieu
qui te dit tu sors demain personne peut
te faire sortir la justice et la justice
les gens sont des êtres humains la seule
différence tu voudrais qu'un juge il
soit bien unique que sa femme lui a fait
l'amour et quand il se lève le matin il
est en pleine forme et il dit Monsieur
Moulis je vous fais un cadeau vous
sortez si sa femme elle l'a jeté il a
dormi dans le fauteuil et ben tu prends
on espère que Gilles Verdez ne sera
jamais juge
merci je veux dire un vrai secret ce
soir ah on m'a toujours dit Marco
essayez de trouver l'énigme on m'a
toujours dit Marcos qui traite de
l'argent j'ai été dans 14 pays j'étais
bourré d'oseille à votre avis donc quel
pays sont c'est ça qu'il faut savoir
dans le livre si un homme intelligent ou
une femme intelligente arrive à le
découvrir je le dirai réellement
mais pas du tout alors écoute-moi bien
alors écoute-moi bien
ne chie pas où tu manges le manges pas
ou tu chies
[Rires]
en fait bah oui
tu sais qu'il y a un bail c'est que tu
ressens de plus en plus
[Musique]
sur ma vie frère tu ressors de plus en
plus à ton cul alors il y a une rumeur
qui dit que l'État aurait essayé de
faire retirer de l'avant de votre livre
est-ce que c'est vrai alors
lui et non oui enfin moi je pense aussi
parce que j'ai vu quelque chose qui
était horrible il y a Harper Collins qui
est mon éditeur qui est des gens
magnifique que j'aime que j'adore et ben
pour de vrai alors et la Fnac a reçu les
premiers livres un carton un vrai carton
normalement tu es libéré tu vends tes
livres tu gagnes de l'oseille puis d'un
seul coup ils veulent pas faire de
Rassort pourquoi donc Julie Madar qui
est très énervé parce que elle y va elle
dit allô ouais ouais non non on nous a
dit de de l'autre côté il s'est
renvoyant d'air on nous a dit de
boycotter le livre et je savais pas ce
que ça veut dire je me dis c'est quoi
bon côté de livre elle m'a dit ils
veulent plus le vendre je lui donne moi
le mec là je vais l'appeler là-bas parce
qu'ils vend des livres dit claire ils
vend des livres de terrorisme ils vont
des livres de pédophile et il veut pas
vendre le mien qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
ça veut dire qu'en réalité dans le lead
il y a des choses c'est que la vérité et
ça va déranger beaucoup de monde dans la
vérité de réussir à passer sans
passeport et des fois avec des
passeports qui ne me ressemblent pas ça
veut dire qu'en vérité c'est le Moulin
Rouge voilà donc c'est facile à passer
et alors tu vas nous raconter ça non non
c'est incroyable ce que tu dis en livre
justement est-ce que tu t'es servi de
cet argent pour cette cavale combien de
temps tu restes en cavale je suis resté
8 mois 6 mois
et tu t'es servi de cet argent parce que
quand on quand on est en cavale on a
besoin d'argent très cher alors ma
cavale elle m'a coûté très très cher
parce que en réalité j'avais envie de
tout dépenser avant de faire 8 ans de
prison tu sais quand tu arrives devant
la barre et le Président il est là et
grâce à mon grâce à mon histoire il est
passé place Vendôme il est passé place
Vendôme non voilà la justice là commence
et quand tu arrives devant le président
et puis il te déteste non
c'est chaque personne a envie de se
mettre sur la tête de quelqu'un pour
essayer de gagner de gagner de
l'espérance de gagner de du grade de
gagner donc il m'a eu comment il m'a eu
et il m'a eu vraiment moi j'avais
calculé pour le virer le président donc
je suis rentré avec mon café ma
cigarette comme ça il gueule avec moi
j'ai pas possible vous m'aimez pas je
vous aime pas faut pas me juger donc il
y a conflit intérêt on change de
président et puis il m'a mis à l'aise
quand il me laissait levé comme ça mais
en criant comme ça il me dit hein ici je
serai impartial
je ferai mon procès quand il m'a dit ça
je l'ai regardé si je veux le croire
celui-là et puis je l'ai cru et puis non
il a pas été impartial parce qu'ils ont
demandé 10 ans j'ai pris 8 mais quand je
me suis fait arrêter en garde à vue à
Marc maintenant j'aime j'ai fait mes 8
ans pas marre arrête arrête tu m'as
fatigué et quand il est venu il m'a dit
tu vas prendre 8 ans et j'ai pris 8 ans
donc Netflix mais il est adorable mais
chéri s'il te plaît il est super mais
est-ce que tu l'as eu moi
j'ai vu dans le doc je l'ai trouvé
incroyable il est devenu procureur avec
Mouli
j'ai rien fait il est drôle il a une
tendresse pour toi en plus de dans le
doc de notre Netflix c'est ce que j'ai
vu il a une tendresse parce que je suis
un garçon qui me laisse pas faire voilà
pourquoi il a une tendresse il aime il
sait quand tu te fais attraper ils ont
des preuves tu dis ok c'est moi mais
tant que tu lisons pas de preuve Tu sais
pas moi mais moi je suis un garçon de
bonne foi quand je me fais attraper je
lève les mains je dis ok vous avez gagné
et je fais ma prison et j'ai pas pleuré
alors raconte-nous un peu ta cavale donc
tu commences par quel pays alors la
cavale je la commence par alors j'étais
à j'étais à Cannes et à Cannes
je te raconter une anecdote qui est vrai
pour ta mère sa mère elle me voit je
l'embrasse et puis je l'ai pas invité à
manger j'ai rien fait j'ai dit [ __ ]
dans le cul pardon c'est pas beau et
puis on a une qui m'a eu j'ai adoré
comment à Mahut pour de vrai elle m'a
dit je suis la sœur à Cyril je savais
pas ouais comment vas-tu et moi je suis
en train de manger et elle est avec ses
deux bébés quelque chose je dis comme
j'avais pas j'avais oublié d'inviter sa
maman j'ai dit mince si toi mange Julie
alors vas-y commencé avec Cyril elle me
dit qui Cyril
n'a pas de bébé
mais bravo elle m'a eu un AR
[Applaudissements]
aqué
un beau billet parce que je lui dis
bravo je lui ai dit bravo je l'avais
deux gosses de folie elle venait de
Lille la pauvre elle voulait être dans
le lit
j'adore
l'île Maurice
là-bas
et les Lillois c'est des amours
juste est-ce que alors donc tu commences
par 4 tu pars à Cannes je pars à Cannes
non d'abord je suis à Cannes ouais mon
procès il est à 9h du matin je le vois à
6h j'arrive je sais qu'il y a des flics
autour de moi parce qu'il savait que
j'allais pas y aller donc je parle avec
un mec je vais venir avec un mec tout de
suite et je lui dis comme ça donc il
faut que je prenne le vol à 6h pour que
j'arrive à 9h là et puis bon ben je vais
aller en prison j'ai préparé mon sac et
tout ça mais je veux qu'ils entendent
les filles tu as compris parce que je me
dis si j'y vais pas ils vont m'arrêter à
Cannes mais comme le mandat d'arrêt il
faut 4 jours ils peuvent pas m'arrêter
mais j'ai dit pour une connerie pour
m'arrêter donc j'ai calculé tout ça
parce que moi je vais je vois loin dans
enfin j'ai toujours des stratégies et
j'arrive comme ça et je lui dis ok je
prends l'avion j'arrive à Paris je mets
une moto à côté je mets une voiture et
je me dis si je prends 8 ans je prends
un peu de recul je m'éclate un petit peu
parce que la prison un peu m'attendre et
là depuis 200 ans elle est là que j'y
vais demain ou dans une semaine voilà je
vais y aller quoi qu'il arrive ils vont
m'attraper un jour ou l'autre et puis
après je je vais donc
je suis aux toilettes et aux toilettes
il y a deux avocats et je commence à
trembler ma race mais trembler trembler
je me sauve je me sens pas non mais j'y
vais je suis un homme je me suis je
reçois un texto 8 ans je prends la robe
je mets la robe je vois une paire de
lunettes rouges je la mets je prends le
téléphone mais je tremble et je marche
les escaliers je t'ai laissé je commence
à courir comme un voleur et là comme un
voleur
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je voulais pas me faire attraper attends
j'enlève ma belle je crois que
je rigole
[Applaudissements]
j'arrive donc je me sauve il y a mon
chauffeur qui s'appelle Mamadou on
l'embrasse que j'adore que
bon lui il est pas dans il est pas il a
rien lui il est pas il a rien il
conduits et il me dit mais pourquoi tu
veux qu'on va pas là pas je te dis qu'on
me surveille il me dit mais qui te
connaît pour qu'on te surveille
[Musique]
tremblais tellement Bam Bam Bam je
prends le train mais là je rencontre un
mec un chanteur et je me dis comment je
fais pour pour éviter beaucoup de
personnes je prends le chanteur je lui
ça va je me dis où tu vas il me dit je
vais dans un bled ok tac tac je suis ta
des sous sur toi il me dit non je suis
un billet de 300 et un billet de train
tu montes avec moi dans le train il me
dit pourquoi faire je suis parce que je
veux que tu me chantes ton train voilà
tu sais je vais oublier un petit peu le
l'atmosphère des flics des trucs et je
sais pas marqué dans le livre ça
j'arrive comme ça et puis là je vois des
chiens des brassards et j'arrive mais il
surveille la drogue dans le train mais
moi je suis bourré d'oseille
tu vois pas qui viennent pour l'oseille
ils peuvent sentir l'oseille les gens je
tremble pas c'est bon après j'ai acheté
avec eux
[Rires]
j'arrive à Cannes à Cannes j'embrasse ma
famille je sais que je veux pas les
revoir j'embrasse mes enfants et voilà
et je leur dis là je prends le bateau et
je pars à vintimides et bon même le mec
il savait tu vois je sais que
normalement Cannes 28000 ça vaut quoi
100000 € et ben voilà il m'a dit on
démarre pas si vous ne donnez pas de
temps il savait que j'étais obligé de
partir je tremblais et là j'ai déchiré
mon passeport je l'ai jeté j'étais chéri
ma carte en été j'ai jeté j'avais plus
de papier et là la cavale commence à 26
mes cheveux vous pouvez pas faire marche
arrière parce que si je faisais marche
arrière je prenais pire que les 8 ans et
voilà et là ça démarre là je vais à
Vintimille et après je vais te dire la
vérité j'étais avec un mec que tu dois
connaître Pinot ne plus gentil garçon du
monde et ma peur elle s'est calmé avec
lui pourquoi parce qu'il avait plus peur
que moi
je comprends pas oui parce qu'il va se
faire arrêter on va se faire arrêter et
à chaque fois ça me coûte un billet de
1000 je suis mais non on va pas se faire
arrêter
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et la carte vous gagnez de l'argent
aussi non non j'ai gagné beaucoup
d'argent je faisais de venir à un mec à
chacun au port et j'ai appelé le mec une
fois que j'étais à la report pour partir
dans un autre pays parce que j'avais
peur et j'ai appelé souvent les douanes
à chaque pays que j'allais j'allais
souvent les douanes j'étais on s'arrange
il me dit comment on s'arrange rien on
s'arrange tu m'attrapes tu te fais
l'honneur que tu m'as attrapé on
s'arrange il me dit ok je te rappelle
alors il me disait dans quel pays tu es
je veux inventer un pays il me dit non
tu es dans ce pays
plutôt où ils sont les caméras et voilà
ça veut dire j'avais franchement ils ont
ils ont fait 14 pays donc il fait Cannes
26000 après tu vas où mais je vais
partout je vais dans tous les pays Maroc
Tunis je vais partout je vais les 14
pays et puis la fin du pays enfin quand
je dis la fin du pays je me suis j'étais
dans un pays où là j'arrive en Israël
mais bon on a peur Pauline ça veut pas
que je le dise mais ça a été la plus
belle chose c'était comment rentrer en
Israël c'est comment parce que une
épingle n'auront pas en Israël tu peux
avoir les 200 faux papiers tu peux avoir
des vrais papiers qui te dis c'est pas à
toi tu la connais à report d'Israël
quand ils arrivent je suis l'homme je
suis bonjour
je suis l'homme pourquoi tu parles pas
hébreu
parce que je suis français
tu as compris donc qui ils sont tu peux
pas rentrer en Israël tu peux pas tu
chies pourquoi tu es là et ben je vais
en vacances pourquoi tu viens en
vacances à la fin tu dis bah je veux pas
y aller tu rentres comme ça tu veux pas
y aller et
voilà j'avais peur de ce pays de passer
dans ce pays et ça a été ma meilleure
rentrée ça a été vraiment ma mère
rentrée tu sais j'ai acheté des
passeports à des gens qui étaient au
restaurant un couple qui était un
restaurant dans un restaurant dans un
bled je veux pas le dire parce qu'il y a
le livre il y a le livre qui tu pouvais
parler tout le livre comment tu veux il
vous dit il vous dit plein de trucs et
voilà c'est vous allez voir là il y a
l'idée tous les détails sont dans les et
puis en plus il y a zéro mensonge
pourquoi il y a Jérôme on change c'est
que le jour où on m'a attrapé à Genève
le jour où on m'attrapage à Genève quand
ils sont arrivés j'allais m'en tirer
mais j'allais m'en tirer réellement ça
veut dire que je vois 40 flics
il m'entoure alors ils mettent les
calibres sur mon chauffeur et sur mon
ami puis moi il me laisse tranquille
je suis dit NON NON Michael bellahcen
pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
tu as envie que faire attraper mais
après tu as la ce temps de survie tu non
je veux pas me faire attraper et puis là
je dis non je comprends pas je suis venu
avec à mon père à 100 millions d'euros
pour investir dans l'immobilier je ne
comprends pas qu'est-ce que vous êtes en
train de faire et j'étais richement à
l'hôtel Richemont et bon l'hôtel
Richmond ça veut dire tu peux pas me
prendre pour un voleur
après ton passage
et j'arrive comme ça qui est le mec qui
me dit le mec il me dit vous êtes
moulimardocher je suis mais désolé mais
je suis venu faire des affaires à Genève
mais c'est qui ce mec vous me parlez ça
fait trois heures ou de vous arrêter les
gens vous faites peur aux gens tout le
monde m'entoure mais je ne comprends pas
j'essaie et le mec je dois voir le Condé
il va avoir sa collègue et lui dit c'est
pas lui
[Applaudissements]
et là on se voit une vie c'est pas lui
j'essaye de crier je dire maintenant ça
suffit je vais vous attaquer ah ouais
oui je parle de l'argent comme ça ils
ont peur mais moi je veux vous attaquer
et puis à la gonzesse qui arrive un
petit c'est lui non moi j'essaie de la
charmer je suis malade calmez-vous c'est
pas moi regardez ma tête regardez ce
moules mardocher elle me dit comment
vous savez qui s'appelle mardocher
chimie et là j'ai eu cons parce que on
m'a appelé Marco là à Genève j'ai dit
parce que j'ai entendu votre collègue
parler de mardeau chez non non on l'a
pas dit et d'un seul coup Flac ça me
fait une photo de mon visage et puis tu
vois la fiche Interpol qui arrive
Interpol qui arrive et je la vois en
plein de gueule mais maintenant j'ai des
papiers sur moi s'il m'arrête avec les
papiers de Michael bellahcen je suis
mort parce que j'ai 8 ans puis je prends
deux ans pour l'autre papier donc je
pense plus d'Inter arrêter je pense
comment je vais avaler le passeport et
je pense qu'à ça tu as compris comment
je vais le manger il roule pas ce soir
et
j'arrive tac tac et là j'ai vu d'un seul
coup quatre voitures arrivées Interpol
un cowboy qui est arrivé que je connais
très bien qui m'arrêtait plusieurs fois
il arrivait il m'a dit alors mon lit je
joue mon ami comment tu vas
dire aujourd'hui je suis pas ton ami je
suis ah bon pourquoi il m'a dit ça fait
6 mois qu'on veut tu nous as fait courir
tu vas morfler
calme-toi moi j'ai rien dit j'allais me
rendre moi j'ai tourné la j'allais me
rendre tu as compris j'allais vous
téléphoner d'abord je savais que vous
étiez à Genève moi j'essaie de les
embrouiller pour dire je me suis rendu
parce que j'avais peur de la France il
m'attendait la France avec des dents
comme ça j'ai dit qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
faire toutes les polices molles et quand
j'arrive j'ai la plus belle embellie du
monde j'arrive je tends à ma m'écouter
j'espère je tombe sur une procureur mais
et j'arrive comme ça je suis avec ça
veut dire du chamallow voilà et j'arrive
comme ça je dis les condés ils
m'interrogent je vous invite au
restaurant je sais pas comme la France
je l'invite au restaurant ils me disent
NON je paye des pizzas à tout le monde
ils m'ont dit d'accord j'ai appelé mon
chauffeur mon chauffeur je lui donne du
500 € de lui 500 € le flic parce que
j'avais pas mon oseille il lui donne 500
euros je t'achète 30 pizzas Julie moi
j'ai quelque chose à dire bon là ils
vont voir que c'est plus vrai enfin ils
vont voir que c'est vrai ça veut dire
mais que c'est vrai que qu'est-ce que
j'ai dit j'ai quelque chose à dire j'ai
le passeport derrière mes fesses j'ai le
passeport ils m'ont pas fouillé j'ai
rien compris et là je dis moi j'ai
besoin de parler à à mon chauffeur il a
j'ai besoin qu'il aille me chercher de
l'argent il me dit combien d'argent je
suis à que 12 millions d'euros mais non
eux ils veulent m'attraper plus les 12
millions d'euros il sera pas CAPA une
tune et là je réussis mon chauffeur il
vient il me parle tu as des flics cachés
à côté pour voir qu'est-ce que j'allais
dire et moi je dis voilà tu vas aller tu
vas derrière je la pizza je mets le
passeport en dessous et le mec met le
mon chauffeur si tu as brutique mange la
pizza
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi je suis là je suis dit mais va
t'en dicta quelque chose à faire et là
il s'est fait suivre et puis le
passeport a disparu et quand je suis
arrivé en France ils m'ont dit comment
vous avez fait pour passer tous ces
frontières et je leur ai dit même moi je
sais pas si j'ai pas à savoir et puis là
il manque donné toutes les preuves
comment je suis passé c'est comme ça que
la cavale mais la cavale est tellement
magnifique je vais te dire la vérité je
veux dire quand je pense aujourd'hui je
te le promets que c'est vrai que je
paierai un an de prison pour la refaire
ça a été la plus belle chose de ma vie
tu vois j'ai dépensé des millions dans
ma vie j'ai kiffé j'ai fait deux fois le
tour du monde j'ai tout vu les
politiques les chanteurs les stars de
tout ce que tu veux j'ai tout vu dans ma
vie mais cette cavale à deux que j'ai
fait avec les larmes que j'ai coulées
avec la peur avec l'adrénaline et tu
sais il y a des moments où je pleurais
mais ne pas faire montrer à Pino que je
pleurais que j'avais peur en vérité
d'aller en prison parce qu'il fallait
souriant et ben je vais te dire
l'émotion et la joie se mélangent bien
voilà Marco Molly